Trascrizione: Maria Pericleous
Revisore: Giulia Sgarbossa
Quanti di noi si sono immedesimati
nei personaggi di questo video?
Quanti di noi negli ultimi due anni
si sono ritrovati in situazioni simili?
Io sinceramente sì.
Con due figli ancora piccoli,
un gatto che adora passeggiare
sulla tastiera del mio computer,
e alle prese con una serie
di incombenze casalinghe
che non nego in tempi non Covid,
sono molto felice di delegare
mi sono rivista in molte
delle situazioni di questo video.
Ma pensandoci bene,
in realtà, quanti di noi,
come i membri di questo team,
si sono sentiti completamente a loro agio
nel condividere aspetti
così privati, senza filtri.
Oppure come Vivienne,
il boss di questo video,
hanno preferito mantenere intatta
la loro immagine professionale,
arrivando magari anche a negare
che quello che stava succedendo
aveva un impatto,
sulle nostre vite private,
sulle nostre vite professionali
e non poteva essere negato.
Questo video, dal titolo
“L’intera faccenda del lavoro da casa”,
è stato pubblicato circa 18 mesi fa,
da una grande azienda americana.
E a me è subito piaciuto tantissimo,
per due motivi principali.
Il primo perché ci permette di sorridere
di un’esperienza difficile, pesante,
che tutti noi abbiamo vissuto
e vorrei dire subito.
Il secondo, perché in pochi minuti
ci dà una visione chiara ed esaustiva
di quanto il Covid,
questa esperienza così dura,
abbia impattato sul concetto
di diversità ed inclusione,
creando una nuova
prospettiva per il futuro.
Il binomio diversità-inclusione
non è un binomio nuovo.
Non è un binomio nuovo
per chi si occupa di pari opportunità,
ma non lo è neppure
per il mondo del business.
Già da anni infatti
le aziende di tanti settori
hanno realizzato
come diversità ed inclusione
siano un fattore fondamentale
per aumentare le performance.
Quindi alla fine aumentare il risultato
economico di queste aziende stesse.
Già nel 2018 uno studio,
condotto e pubblicato dalla Deloitte,
dai Diversity and Inclusion Revolution,
ci diceva che la diversità
genera un incremento del 20%
nella capacità delle aziende di innovare,
e riduce del 30% i rischi connessi.
Allo stesso modo, uno stile
di leadership inclusivo
permette di aumentare del 17%
le performance di un team,
di migliorare del 20% la qualità
delle decisioni che questo team prende,
e di aumentare del 29%
la collaborazione all’interno del team.
Sono numeri importanti
che nessuno oggigiorno, volente o meno
nell’area del business
può permettersi di ignorare.
Nel frattempo negli anni
il concetto stesso
di diversità è cambiato.
Siamo partiti dalla diversità demografica:
razza, età, genere,
che è un pilastro fondamentale,
e che va protetto e rispettato,
ma che da solo non è sufficiente.
Va integrato con un concetto
di diversità di pensiero,
una diversità cognitiva
che è legata alle esperienze,
all’educazione,
finanche alla struttura mentale
di ciascuno di noi.
Cosa è successo?
Siamo passati da una diversità
basata sulle categorie,
a una diversità relativa
al singolo individuo,
in un processo che potremmo chiamare
di personalizzazione
della diversità stessa.
Secondo voi,
se lo stesso team si fosse trovato
in una normale sessione di brainstorming,
seduto all’interno
di un’asettica sala riunioni,
sarebbe riuscito ad arrivare
con la stessa facilità
a questa idea del nido d’ape
che tra l’altro nel video si vede,
si è rivelata poi fondamentale, vincente.
Secondo me, no.
Quello che è successo è che questo team
ha messo in gioco una serie di elementi
legati alla loro vita privata,
ha condiviso opportunità,
anche magari inconsapevolmente,
che gli hanno permesso di arrivare
più velocemente alla soluzione.
E che cosa dire del fatto
che condividendo più di sé,
conoscendosi meglio,
questo team creerà un’empatia maggiore
che li aiuterà ad affrontare
le difficoltà connesse con il loro lavoro.
Il Covid ha apportato
un’accelerazione estrema
al concetto di diversità.
Ha asportato, ha cambiato completamente
il terreno di gioco, volenti o meno,
ci ha spostato da quello che è
il singolo individuo,
alle diverse sfaccettature
del singolo individuo
che sono caratteristiche dei diversi ruoli
che ciascuno di noi, in ogni momento
della propria vita, ricopre.
Ha abbattuto le barriere
fra vita professionale e vita privata,
è entrato nelle nostre case,
nelle nostre dinamiche familiari,
però, allo stesso tempo,
ha creato un’opportunità:
ha creato l’opportunità
di mettere in gioco risorse ed energie
che solitamente manteniamo, invece,
confinate in uno dei tanti
ruoli che abbiamo.
Ha rimescolato le carte,
ha abbattuto le barriere
fra i diversi ruoli,
quello di mamma, di manager, di moglie,
e ci ha permesso veramente
di creare energie nuove.
Fin qua tutto positivo.
Ma che cosa serve,
affinché questa esperienza,
nata da una situazione
difficile come il Covid,
possa diventare in realtà
un’esperienza sostenibile,
una condizione sostenibile nel futuro.
Circa un anno dopo il primo lockdown,
io e il mio management team
ci siamo ritrovati a riflettere.
Ci siamo ritrovati a parlare di che cosa?
Che cosa ci serve,
affinché queste nuove risorse
possano essere utilizzate al meglio.
La diversità è fondamentale,
affinché le persone si sentano libere
di esprimere maggiormente parti di sé,
soprattutto parti sempre più private,
quello che è fondamentale è l’inclusione
e sono alcune caratteristiche
tipiche dell’inclusione,
il rispetto, il sentirsi
parte di un team, il sentirsi gratificati,
la capacità dei leader e dei manager
di creare un ambiente trasparente,
aperto, e psicologicamente sicuro.
Questi sono gli elementi chiave
che ci permetteranno di valorizzare
quelle energie e quelle risorse
che abbiamo messo in campo.
Ma quanto siamo pronti a farlo?
Di nuovo, un anno fa abbiamo riflettuto
sul che cosa serve,
affinché questo succeda?
E l’abbiamo fatto,
riflettendo sui feedback che abbiamo
collezionato nel nostro team.
Tutti noi, nostro malgrado,
abbiamo accettato che la vita lavorativa
entrasse nelle nostre case,
nelle nostre cucine,
qualche volta, logistica permettendo,
anche nelle nostre camere da letto.
Il numero di stanze
magari non era sufficiente,
affinché ognuno ne avesse una,
e quindi anche le camere da letto
si sono aperte al mondo professionale.
Però ci risulta ancora difficile
permettere invece agli aspetti
più privati della nostra vita,
ai nostri figli, ai nostri fratelli,
ai nostri genitori,
ai nostri animali domestici,
di prendere parte a quella
che è la nostra vita lavorativa.
Condividere lo spazio lavorativo,
condividere il monitor.
In base a questa riflessione,
abbiamo pensato di scrivere una mail,
per rassicurare i nostri colleghi,
le persone che lavorano con noi,
del fatto che riconosciamo,
e dobbiamo essere tutti orgogliosi,
di quello che stiamo facendo,
di avere aperto le nostre case,
di aver condiviso la nostra vita privata,
e non ci dobbiamo sentire in difficoltà
se il figlio per esempio si affaccia,
mentre stiamo facendo una riunione,
oppure se il gatto o il cane appaiono,
mentre stiamo facendo qualcosa.
Io credo che questo genere
di comunicazioni sia fondamentale.
Però non è sufficiente.
E come spesso accade,
quello che invece è necessario
è l’esempio del leader, del manager,
di chi ha responsabilità su altre persone.
Non basta a rassicurare,
è necessario dare l’esempio,
mostrare qualcosa di sé prima.
A me piace tantissimo questo video,
in cui questo personaggio famoso,
in una conferenza importante,
non la solita videoconferenza
fra collaboratori,
ha permesso al figlio,
di poco più di un anno,
di partecipare,
di sedersi insieme al padre,
e gli ha ritagliato uno spazio suo,
in cui anche lui ha potuto
essere parte, prendere parte
a quello che il padre stava facendo.
C’è un altro elemento fondamentale,
un altro ruolo che il leader ha
in questo percorso,
ed è quello di garante.
Se la scelta dei social media,
di essere su un social
piuttosto che un altro,
e di quanto condividiamo sui social
è una scelta personale.
Lo smart working negli ultimi due anni,
per molti di noi non è stata una scelta,
è stata una necessità.
In questo processo,
dobbiamo ricordare che la condivisione
e la sbarra dove e quanto
vogliamo condividere
di ciascuno di noi e del nostro privato,
deve sempre rimanere
una scelta del singolo,
una scelta che va tutelata e rispettata.
Quindi il Covid-19
ha fatto da acceleratore
a questo percorso della diversità
e dell’inclusione.
Ci ha spostato dalla diversità demografica
a una diversità più privata
che include le diverse sfaccettature
di ciascuno di noi.
Ci ha ricordato quanto
fondamentale sia l’inclusione,
quanto sia necessario creare
per ciascuno di noi
uno spazio sicuro, trasparente,
in cui sentirsi riconosciuti,
apprezzati e gratificati.
Ci ha ricordato il ruolo
del leader come esempio,
non come colui che manda comunicazione,
ma come colui che mostra per primo
che non bisogna avere paura
di permettere alla vita privata
di entrare in quella professionale.
E ultimo punto ma fondamentale.
Quando si parla di vita privata,
quando si parla di condivisione di noi,
questa condivisione deve essere,
e deve rimanere una scelta personale,
e come tale va tutelata.
Grazie.
(Applausi)